how's it going bros my name is Pippa
welcome to episode 3 of me Sean it's
very exciting let's keep playing
what just happened oh yeah we had him
did you see Donna don't worry about it
said Donald dud
he's my favorite cartoon that rain is so
cool ok just thinking about someone I
wants to do
sure Missouri or the actress of that how
to get away with murder I'd do that too
the old chair scars John he he went to
talk to the kids make sure they're all
right well I watched over you
sorry about this John isn't big on
people he doesn't know what kind of
question is that what's that for
shooting people
rabbits mostly possum once in a while if
we get lucky
I'm actually taste decent if you cook it
right that's disgusting I would never
eat a possum so yeah this is where I
apologize for almost shooting you Oh
Unni doesn't sound almost I was just
worried it's all in the past no I guess
not
I'm gonna shoot you like a possum next
time makes you feel any better I'm not a
great shot that does not make me feel
better
no I'm poor kid that patch of dirt his
mom's buried there
you're so Bakshi just damn that you did
not have to do this Nick not in the head
something with her heart
is their belly hurt because I can relate
to that
yeah she couldn't handle it I guess
sometimes this world is too much for
people sometimes you mean all the time
I wasn't for Sam
sar band a Gram stain
oh she's wake I'm here Sam hey don't
move okay don't move
yeah no I'm set hahaha mission we have
to help him he's dead sorry
yep just stay down Sam Sam Greg is dead
no Greg Sam
yep as sad as it is right stay ahead
it's my fault too got lemon drink it's
supposed to be good for the belly thank
you Bruce I appreciate it
I know John can make a strong first
impression but he's what's keeping this
entire family from being buried out
there well you got to fight like hell
for what you care about right right
something that makes all this [ __ ] worth
it
yeah fight until the day you die
man it seems I I would have just popped
it seems like way too much effort to
stay alive to stay here John they don't
have internet so the soda - I need a
word with you why in private I hate when
people do that
listen just pull me off and talk to me
don't [ __ ] make a big deal out of it
goddamn it I hate that who does that get
out of here if you want to talk to me
just talk to me all right you know what
I mean yeah you're filming filming Ryoga
y in the rain damn it's unnecessary
all right so we're at the down part of
the series seems a bit slow let's talk
to this dad whose son we killed but Dada
we say looks like I do to little girls
then we can relate it's not the mom
oh damn it snowed the day my wife died
her heart gave up Sam found her she she
passed in her sleep so she was an Walker
we buried her so the boys wouldn't have
to see her like that
the snow had covered her grave
erased it like she'd never been there at
all
Paige said she killed herself
hi awkward I want my children to think
with her mother differently to wonder
why she given up
ever since Sophia I've tried to keep our
family from horn over falling apart
piece by piece and now that Sam's hurt I
think Craig's DeeDee
I could really use your help your friend
Pete told me all about Norma about what
happened if she finds us we wouldn't
stand a chance but you seem like someone
who can hold her own
Sam said you could help me if you do
that I'll give you guys a hand anything
whatever you need I don't know how we're
gonna help them there's so many more
people than art less they have guns and
[ __ ] we don't have Jensen shouldn't have
to see this Greg never turned into one
of these things did he love those
whatever they are
no he was Greg until the end oh thank
god do you think I did the wrong thing
and lying about that I don't know I
don't know what's the right thing move
you know if it made him happier than I
think it's okay to lie it really doesn't
matter I I'm sorry
I'm trying to keep it together but what
if you just found out your daughters
were dead well they're awkward their
name is very awkward you're miles away
safe and sound
how would you feel
your kids need you to stay strong you
you're right
I'm all they have excuse me what the
[ __ ] awkward timing are you [ __ ] me
right now what the [ __ ] does happen
trapped like a red find her oh [ __ ] man
they really want me gone don't they
[ __ ] hell they just shot him as soon
as he said oh my god that's crazy this
is crazy let's go left
No
let's go right
I'll tell you one near the fountain
let's go it's me Sean so hi
Miguel here we go I'm gonna go where our
don't turn around June turn around can't
see me [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] ghost
I bet your name is Barry isn't it yeah
[ __ ] here we go
going closer I am the danger here we go
boom Shakalaka oh hey sorry about that
mate gonna take this good night yeah
what are you gonna do that's right
that's what happens if you [ __ ] with me
Sean um what what the [ __ ] was that
that was timed get Adi
alright fine whatever alright dum-dum
okay that was my fault I am in it
bündchen 9 yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] oh this
bad
yeah I'm so sick of that guy holy [ __ ]
yeah that's right me Sean time it's me
Sean time oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
Sean's getting an ass-beating shove up
come on me Sean oh that's gotta hurt
say hi to table tastes good doesn't it
oh ah more give me more another one no
you got to do more
all right snot dad walk him in lock him
in okay all right all right what is up
with the gore can we calm down a little
bit you all right
not dead yet aah you broke my left leg
I'm fine
happens every once in a while Oh
hmm what's cracking Oh your fingers baby
[ __ ]
you must be pretty proud of yourself huh
no we're gonna tickle yourself with
golden goose hey whoa you don't mess
around
I like that
you have this Norma know we're here she
doesn't even know I'm here
otherwise you'd be here and enabling
knock on your door right about now
Randall Randall are you getting this
want to get that for me uh-huh we heard
gunshots if you don't check in on
sentence everyone in that direction [ __ ]
she soon spin Randall pick up goddamnit
you gonna answer talk to her Michelle
don't make the same mistake if you hurt
her Randall needs to check in you know
this feels mighty familiar except you're
there and I'm here so Miss Sean what do
you want me to say to her on account of
me hoping to avoid more broken fingers
your wish is my command like she said
check in let her know you're fine yeah
yeah I got it I'll play nice
hey Randall are you alright yeah yeah
everything's fine
hey I wasn't finished yet
I was doing what you said Monsieur you
said all you need it - nice try
yeah stop that [ __ ] shut him down
Randall I love you Oh what what were you
saying
have a girl huh normal no something's
wrong soon enough I can find you
she'll find you whatever this alone time
you owe me together it's been real nice
but that all ends when my sister gets
here I'm gonna take that Ridge and break
your skull then Sam's yours
last but not least
those kiddies - oh my god I saw their
little heads in the window
kids you know their skulls don't break
sausages
kind of melt
yes I hit a button we shown my god don't
just enter your [ __ ] dumb don't you
to look like your daddy why do they
enter that we're still faced yet out of
here
oh my god what ya got a big hole there
good job good job good job why did you
enter please tell me you [ __ ] with us
Sam get out of here
he killed my dad but why is it this son
of a [ __ ] dead first good question
asked all night Jones just fumble around
like a bear cub [ __ ] a football he
keeps opening his mouth he'll be dead
soon we should do it right [ __ ] now
all she wants is her brother back that's
it we're out of the equation you need to
kill him or I will
I can't have to agree he's way too
dangerous to keep a leg
wait this is get kind of annoying but to
be honest a you're just gonna do
whatever you want anyway yeah I am
already made up your mind
Thanks nice bracelet you keep I ain't
know how to battle of the block well
maybe that's you is when this days is
over
oh damn [ __ ] let me live our rebellious
[ __ ] we both know how this has gone in
your shop you like killing
and you like yummy
just telling the truth I get big skin
you're right about that
feels good to get that out in the open
don't it well maybe maybe you think you
crys bubble does Calum but there ain't
no heaven up there
there's only [ __ ] every day until you
died then you know what's the [ __ ]
kicker you get up and keep walking
hey some biblical [ __ ] there's still
a chance we can make things better don't
tell me you still believe that live show
this is world your kids are dying in
Michele what Brett diet or in that
[ __ ] purgatory shut up don't talk
about that by the way they're suffering
and mommy isn't there
we all have our demons so Oh should I do
it summer sitting right in front of us
what God brings a child this mess
blue skies for them good night
oh did you see that maybe look at that
[ __ ] baby
I mean don't look baby don't look it's
gonna be okay
nailed it
damn this episode seen tens yo Oh God
excuse me instead it's dabeli I feels
good that relieves that relieves the
pressure if you know what I mean that's
right did I make it better I bet it did
a little slimy [ __ ] man can the loading
screens always be awkward between us
please it's it's our thing
I get it it's cool this is just going on
weight alone thank you oh okay that was
the end and it crashed that's not good
see if we can redo that let me show
oh stop loading an update that's the
thing about these they're a little wonky
I would say these games this one was
sure there's just an hour shadow mind
I think it was a good length on this one
it was very intense I got to say I
really really really really it's
updating its dummling in an update I
really really really enjoyed this one a
lot more than the first one because it
was more focused on Michonne and than
anything uh-oh
it didn't crash alright let's watch it
time on me shine okay a lot of time in
green where you only have your thoughts
a company
and those can be mean nasty
nice boys don't running for my life
business things always fall where don't
want to bring them down
or get put into flames man she knows how
to pose me Sean please oh look who made
the right choices except that one time
did you keep Pete with you or let him go
off on his own so most people stop Keith
that's good
cuz yeah he was pretty like why would we
leave him I know I don't care but it's
like don't don't be a hero all right
you're not the hero me Sean Stu here did
you pick up the phone or go after the
footsteps in the hallway
most people just picked up the phone
well we the thing is the footsteps could
have been literally [ __ ] anyone
thinking about it in retrospect it
probably made more sense to go for the
footsteps because we could have stopped
him and we could have just hit redial on
the phone although we would have known
that the girl died actually she did die
but whatever I don't [ __ ] know did
you reveal to page that you nearly
commit a suicide
I don't remember that how do you handle
the radio call from Norma you and 6%
choose to make Randall speak to her what
did you do to Randall Oh half people let
half of you let him live what's wrong
with you you're gonna let that
psychopath go around killing children
just because you don't like the idea of
killing someone well I bet you you want
me to rub your belly while you're at it
my belly is the one that hurts all right
anyway that was episode two of Walking
Dead thank you so much for watching
really appreciate it leaving a like it
really helps out and support the series
and thank you so much for watching I'll
see you in the next one I'll play it for
sure and as always stay awesome brush